es hätte schlimmer kommen können für die
Demokraten aber immer noch droht einen
Comeback der trampisten America first
das kann allerdings auch Joe Biden schon
ganz gut Berlin ist verärgert bis
entsetzt über 430 Milliarden Dollar
Subventionen für US-Firmen und der
Bundesfinanzminister warnt vor einem
Handelskrieg Washington wiederum wirft
den Deutschen vor sie zahlten zu wenig
für die Ukraine und machten zugute
Geschäfte mit China welchen Weg soll
Deutschland gehen zwischen Bündnistreue
und Eigennutz das fragen wir uns und
diese Gäste Christian Lindner
Bundesfinanzminister und FDP-Chef
Politologe aus Washington
die Wirtschaftsweise Ulrike malmedia
Helene Bobrowski Journalistin der FAZ
und SPD-Chef Lars Klingbeil sie sind zu
Gast bei Maybrit Illner
und die begrüßt die Gäste der Runde
ausgesprochen herzlich los geht's
Amerika hat gewählt und Deutschland
macht sich Sorgen
wieder haben sich die Demoskopen geirrt
die rote Welle ist ausgeblieben
[Musik]
und diesmal heißt der Verlierer Trump
seine Hand verlesenen Kandidaten sind
hinter den Erwartungen geblieben
Ablenkungsmanöver
ich möchte die Fake News Medien begrüßen
die da hinten stehen da sind verdammt
viele Leute
verloren aber gefühlt gewonnen hat der
Präsident doch eine republikanische
Mehrheit im Repräsentantenhaus würde
beidens Politik sabotieren vom Klima bis
zur Ukraine für uns bedeutet das Europa
und Deutschland werden noch viel stärker
zur Kasse gebeten
unter Republikanern gibt es keinen
einzigen Penny mehr für die Ukraine
unser Land steht an erster Stelle
[Musik]
es wird einsamer um uns herum egal ob
der US-Präsident beiden
Trump oder rondecentes heißt der
Gouverneur von Florida ist der heimliche
Sieger der mit terms 44 Jahre stramm
konservativ h-wort und jerlabsolvent ein
Trump mit Hirn und gerade deshalb noch
gefährlicher für Europa als das Original
ich habe gerade erst begonnen zu kämpfen
[Applaus]
Ulrike mal minier ist bei uns Ökonomen
Mitglied des Sachverständigenrates und
in Kalifornien zu Hause da leben und
arbeiten sie von meinem Handy vor der
Wahl sagten viele die amerikanische
Demokratie steht auf dem Spiel ist sie
jetzt gerettet
naja seit den Ergebnissen schlafe ich
schon ein bisschen ruhiger muss ich
sagen obwohl es weniger jetzt die genaue
Prozentzahl von sitzen die verteilt
wurden ist die mich da ein klein
bisschen beruhigt hat sondern
insbesondere das was gerade im Beitrag
auch betont wurde dass nicht alle der
Trump verlesenen Kandidaten
durchgekommen sind und das ist jetzt
mehr oder minder zum ersten Mal das ist
ein relativ großen Umfang passiert ist
gibt es also Hoffnung dass dieses
Lügengebäude der gestohlenen Wahl und
die Kandidaten die das unterstützen
diejenigen sind die durchkommen wenn das
in der Tat der Fall wäre dann hätte ich
so langsam Hoffnung dass die
amerikanische Demokratie gerettet ist
sie gerettet ist zugeschaltet aus
Washington ist der Politikberater Peter
rau heraus sie sind Republikaner ist es
aus ihrer Sicht nur eine Frage der Zeit
bis dann in zwei Jahren die Republikaner
im Weißen Haus sitzen egal ob es Trump
ist oder descent ist
naja da kann man schwer heute in den
Lagebericht über den 20 jänner 2025
erstellen da sind noch Meilen von
Politik die bevor uns stehen sicherlich
war der gestrige Amt oder vorgestern und
das wird heute ja noch ausgezählt etwas
enttäuschend aber ich glaube er wirkte
überhaupt enttäuschend für ganz Amerika
wir haben über Jahrzehnte in den USA
eine Mehrheit der Demokratischen Partei
im Unterhausen Beispiel erlebt die wurde
1994 durchbrochen durch die Republikaner
die dann wiederum bis 2006 regieren
dürften aber seit 2006 erkennt man in
den USA eine bestimmte Unzufriedenheit
massive Schwankungen in den
Wahlergebnissen bei diesen
Zwischenwahlen 2010 haben die Demokraten
müssen abdanken 2018 wiederum die
Republikaner und bei jüngsten Prognosen
schaut so aus als ob die Republikaner
gerade noch die Mehrheit diesmal
gewinnen werden das heißt die Demokraten
werden abdanken müssen und diese
Unzufriedenheit diese Sehnsucht nach
etwas anderen deutet vielleicht
daraufhin dass der eine Lichtstrahl im
Dunklen für die Republikaner der
fulminante Sieg fronte Center sind
Folder ist wobei ich schon sagen bei der
Anmoderation es wäre es niemand wie run
the Santes außenpolitisch sich
aufstellen wird der hat sich zu diesem
Thema noch nicht wirklich geäußert der
hat nur wie eine Bodenwalze in Florida
die Demokraten geschlagen das ist der
schlechteste Ergebnis für die Demokraten
in Florida in den Nachkriegsgeschichte
und da meine ich den Krieg den
Bürgerkrieg in 19 Jahrhundert der der
USA also wirklich ein guter Sieg und das
ist vielleicht weil er ja man kann sagen
mit Kühnheit auch wagemutig regiert hat
und gezeigt dass er kann die
tropistischen Kandidaten hingegen die
Trump gepusht hat die er rekrutiert hat
haben mit Dreistigkeit muss man sagen
und Überheblichkeit Amte angesucht und
umgegriffen da werden im Senat ohne jede
politische Erfahrung und ich glaube das
war vielleicht verlockend das Vorbild
dass man ohne Lebenslauf sich für den
Senator oder den gouverneursitz überall
kandidieren kann das hat nicht gezogen
Trump hat verloren das Ende hat eine
guten Abend gehabt aber bis 2025 sind
wir doch Meilen entdeckt dann danken wir
für diesen Blick in die Zukunft
Christian Lindner ist bei uns der
Bundesfinanzminister und Chef der FDP
Herr Lindner egal wer regiert Joe Biden
oder einen Republikaner die nächsten
zwei Jahre wird es auf jeden Fall ja
noch zu beiden sein es wird
ungemütlicher für die deutschen
es hat jetzt kein eindeutigen Gewinner
keinen eindeutigen Verlierer gegeben das
ist klar und für mich ist die Konsequenz
daraus dass die Vereinigten Staaten in
der nächsten Zeit und sicherlich einige
Jahre schwer auszurechnen schwer
berechenbar sein werden Konsequenz für
uns als Europäerinnen und Europäer umso
klarer müssen wir in unseren
strategischen Entscheidungen sein zum
anderen
will ich nicht die Anhänger von Trump
und die beiden Administrationen
gleichsetzen ich glaube da gibt es große
Unterschiede gerade wenn man überlegt
wie der Machtwechsel seinerzeit
begleitet worden ist da gibt es große
Unterschiede nur beim Auftreten auf der
internationalen Bühne wir sprechen ja
gleich noch über Handelsbeziehungen darf
man sich keiner Illusion hingeben dass
die Demokraten oder die Republikaner in
gänzlich anderer Weise Europa begegnen
würden lassen Sie mich im letzten
Gedanken nur sagen weil man ja gesehen
hat wie enorm polarisiert die
amerikanische Gesellschaft ist in
politischer Hinsicht
das sollten wir auch uns zu Herzen
nehmen und eine Konsequenz daraus ziehen
man kann zwischen Regierungen
Oppositionen oder zwischen Parteien
unterschiedliche Meinungen haben und
demokratischer Ideen Wettbewerb ist
richtig und wichtig aber diese Form der
Feindschaft bis hin zu
vernichtungsphantasien die es in den USA
gibt das sollte für uns ein
abschreckendes Beispiel sein unsere
politische Kultur zu pflegen wir nehmen
die Gedanken auf sind dankbar dass Lars
klingen bei auch bei uns ist der Chef
der SPD einer von zwei Vorsitzenden der
Sozialdemokratie was wir in dem Beitrag
gehört haben und was Peter rau ein
bisschen relativieren wollte ist das
natürlich auch die Unterstützung für die
Ukraine geringer werden kann seitens der
Amerikaner die Amerikaner gehen
grundsätzlich davon aus dass der Anteil
der Europäer wachsen muss vor allen
Dingen wahrscheinlich auch der deutsche
Anteil wachsen muss da sind sich
Demokraten Republikaner ganz bestimmt
einig zu sagen zahlt mehr für diesen
Krieg was glauben sie Folter auf
Deutschland zu also erstmal muss man
glaube ich schon festhalten dass wir
gerade in der jetzigen weltpolitischen
Lage in der wir sind als deutsche sehr
froh sein können dass Joe Biden im
Weißen Haus sitzt wir hatten davor die
Fähre Donald Trump Christian Lindner ist
jetzt Teil der Regierung ich bin das
nicht aber alles was ich auch von den
spd-regierungsvertretern höre ist dass
das transatlantische Verhältnis die
Zusammenarbeit lange nicht so gut und
belastbar war wie das gerade mit der
beiden Regierung der Fall ist das ist
gut und ich glaube übrigens auch dass
nach diesem Wahlergebnis da substanziell
sich nicht vieles dann ändern wird aber
klar ist aber auch dass es seit Jahren
die deutliche Forderung der Amerikaner
gibt wir müssen mehr machen wir haben
jetzt auch in dieser Regierung mehr
gemacht wenn wir an Sicherheit denken
100 Milliarden Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr das ist etwas wo wir ganz
klar zeigen auch mit dem klaren Ziel des
Erreichens zwei Prozent Ziels wir werden
hier mehr Verantwortung übernehmen und
ich sage ja auch mal sehr deutlich das
ist ja nicht nur weil die Amerikaner das
wollen sondern ich finde auch richtig
dass wir als Bundesrepublik Deutschland
sagen wir wollen als
Bundesland in einem starken Europa wir
wollen viel souveräner selbstbewusster
auch deutliche auftreten unsere
Interessen definieren ich halte das für
ganz wichtig dass wir uns bewusst werden
wie positionieren wir uns eigentlich auf
der weltpolitischen Karte weil wir nicht
wissen was nach 2024 passiert wer dann
im Weißen Haus ist wir sehen reden wir
gleich noch drüber wie Amerika auftritt
wie China auftritt und da muss
Deutschland stärker werden und da haben
wir eine Verantwortung und es wird
Führungsmacht haben sie in den Mund
genommen da sind wir Helene Bobrowski
von der fatz bei der Frage werden uns
die zwei Jahre bis zur Wahl der bis zur
Präsidentenwahl in den Vereinigten
Staaten reichen um diese Führungsmacht
zu werden naja wenn man mal zurückschaut
dann ist diese Idee ja nicht gänzlich
neu also ich meine 2014 hat schon damals
Ursula von der Leyen und der damalige
Präsident der bundespräsident Gauck
diesen Anspruch formuliert dass
Deutschland aktiver werden müsse
militärisch übrigens auch in der in der
Investition in die Bundeswehr und
anderes und hat den Begriff auch der
führungsmarkt damals schon gelegt das
sind jetzt acht Jahre und man also da
klaffenanspruch und Wirklichkeit
schlicht auseinander jetzt haben sie das
den den Begriff der Führungsmacht wieder
eingeführt die
bundesverteidigungsministerin hat das
auch formuliert und man fragt sich aber
was folgt jetzt daraus also sehen wir
jetzt wirkliche Veränderung ja es gibt
die 100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr
aber
Führungsmacht auch militärische bedeutet
natürlich auch mehr ja das bedeutet auch
militärisches Engagement das bedeutet
auch dass man in Europa die Konflikte
die es gibt
ja nicht nur mit einbringen ja genau
löst und das und das kann das ist ja
auch verständlich dass die Amerikaner
sich fragen also wenn man sich mal
anschaut diese nach wie vor Kanadier und
Amerikaner im Baltikum stationiert
schützen die Ostflanke der NATO da kann
man sich auch man kann sich auch eine
kanadische Familie mal fragen warum sind
eigentlich unsere Soldaten dort das ist
ganz schön weit weg aus kanadischer
Sicht also die Forderung an Europa und
an Deutschland insbesondere als ein Land
in der Mitte von Europa ein Land mit
einer besonderen auch historischen
Verantwortung für das was in Europa
passiert ein starkes wirtschaftliches
Land natürlich muss das auch den Worten
auch Taten folgen lassen Frau
mannendiert würden Sie sagen dass man
davon Deutschland in den Vereinigten
Staaten auch erwartet dass das
militärische mit inkludiert also dass
wir auch einen größeren Anteil
militärisch leisten müssen ja ich würde
sagen dass es in Amerika viel mehr Teil
des Selbstverständnisses ist wie man
andere Länder unterstützt als das bei
uns der Fall ist es natürlich auch
historisch bedingt gleichzeitig möchte
ich aber auch betonen dass wir jetzt
diese ganze Diskussion an den
Wahlergebnissen aufgehangen haben ich
bin mir da gar nicht so sicher ob jetzt
die dünne Mehrheit der Republikaner ja
oder nein dann großen Unterschied machen
wird es gibt ja auch eine große Fraktion
unter den Republikanern die für starke
Unterstützung der Ukraine sind die das
als Proxy Warwick gegen Putin sehen und
dann umgekehrt bei den Demokraten welche
sagen mir sowas tun nicht soll lassen
wir doch die anderen mal machen insofern
bin ich da eigentlich so oder so nicht
davon überzeugt dass jetzt die große
Änderung kommt aber gleichzeitig wäre
Lindner gerade gesagt haben mache ich
mir große Sorgen um die Art und Weise
wie politisch diskutiert wird also ich
sehe die Lage als extrem volatil an egal
was die mehr als Verhältnisse sind wenn
es in politisch opportun ist dann kann
das schnell umkippen weil man es gerade
gut nutzen kann für irgendeine Wahl das
macht mir immer also auch Kevin
McCartney von den Republikanern erst
Sprecher der Republikaner im
Repräsentantenhaus der hatte noch gesagt
genau diese bemerkt die Menschen werden
in einer Rezession stecken und sie
werden keinen Blankoscheck für die
Ukraine ausstellen das werden sie
einfach nicht machen
so Kevin McCarthy ist jetzt nicht
irgendjemand Herr Lindner die Frage nach
dem Blankoschecks ist da eindeutig
beantwortet es gibt natürlich auch die
Demokraten die genauso kritisch auf
diese hohen Milliardenzahlungen der
US-Amerikaner in Bezug auf die Ukraine
schauen Frage an den Finanzminister wie
wird dieses europäische Paket und vor
allen Dingen der deutsche Beitrag dazu
aussehen wenn monatlich 1,5 Milliarden
Euro an die Ukraine zu überweisen sind
wie hoch ist der deutsche Beitrag
also ich habe keine Anzeichen dass die
Vereinigten Staaten ihre Politik in
Bezug auf die Ukraine verändern ich habe
regelmäßig Austausch auch mit meiner
amerikanischen Amtskollegin wir sind
gegenwärtig ja g7-präsidentschaft als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und haben
deshalb auch eine besondere strategische
Verantwortung die Gespräche zu führen
und ich kann daraus nicht jetzt ableiten
dass es eine grundlegende Veränderung
gibt wie gerade gesagt worden ist die
USA sehen auch die besondere Bedeutung
dieses Kriegs in geopolitischer Hinsicht
dann geht es nicht nur um unsere
Mitmenschlichkeit natürlich vor allem um
unsere Mitmenschlichkeit aber nicht nur
um unsere Mitmenschlichkeit sondern da
geht es auch um die europäische
Sicherheitsarchitektur da geht es um die
Werte der liberalen Demokratien dass
jedes Land
seinen Weg selbstbestimmt bezogen auf
ihre USA ist enorm stellt ja niemand in
Frage Unterstützung der USA ist enorm
allerdings will ich sagen dass die
Deutschen Steuerzahlerinnen und Skala
den zweitgrößten Anteil weltweit leisten
USA Nummer 1 Deutschland ist Nummer 2
hinsichtlich der militärischen
Unterstützung die wir leisten und das
heißt nicht nur Waffen die wir liefern
sondern auch Mittel Finanzmittel die wir
bereitstellen und auch die Unterstützung
des laufenden Haushalts der Ukraine für
die staatsfunktion wird stark von uns
geleistet Blick nach vorn Frau ellner
also der
monatliche Finanzbedarf des ukrainischen
Staates wird in etwa qualifiziert mit
drei Milliarden US-Dollar im Monat die
dieser Staat braucht für Gehälter
Pensionen und so weiter drei Milliarden
US-Dollar vielleicht vier man kann es
nicht ganz keine abschätzen aber das ist
die Größenordnung und wir haben jetzt
vor in Europa ein Verfahren zu
entwickeln das heißt die Europäische
Union nicht Deutschland allein sondern
die Europäische Union wird ihren Anteil
übernehmen in einer Größenordnung von
1,5 Milliarden Büro wollen wir die
finanzierungsbedürfnisse der Ukraine
unterstützen durch langfristige Kredite
der Europäischen Union an die Ukraine
ich könnte das jetzt wenn sie mich
bitten genauer technisch erläutern wie
das wie das geht aber nur auf Nachfrage
sie sehen so aus als nein
nicht danach als würde Deutschland auch
an dieser Stelle schon massiv Hilfe
leisten wir leisten massiv Hilfe wir
werden im nächsten Jahr wie bereits die
Bundesregierung entschieden hat zwei
Milliarden Euro eigene Zuschüsse fürs
militärleisten nur laufende
staatsfunktion der Ukraine machen wir
jetzt endlich europäisch gemeinsam ich
sage es ganz offen in diesem Jahr das
kam ja alles über uns und dann haben die
G7 Staaten die internationalen
Finanzinstitutionen wieder Währungsfonds
Europäische Union so in einem
improvisierten Verfahren gearbeitet und
die Bundesregierung hat immer darauf
gedrungen dass wir ein Plan waren
nachhaltigen regelbasierten Mechanismus
bekommen damit wir nicht alle vier
Wochen gewissermaßen bei Null anfangen
und zum rumgehen wer Leistung
aus und ich sage noch mal ich habe keine
Anzeichen dass die USA ihre Politik
grundlegend verändern wir sind bei Peter
rau und sagen nochmal Herr rowdis das
was die USA bisher tut in Europa bei der
Unterstützung der Ukraine der
europäischen Verbündeten innerhalb der
NATO immens ist aber und hier kommt das
aber dass wir vorhin schon andeuteten
die Europäer leiden viel mehr als die
Amerikaner unter den Sanktionen die
auferlegt wurden denken sie dass die
Europäer das auch die deutschen da im
Grunde größere Opfer bringen für die
Ukraine als die Amerikaner
ja beim wesentlichen wegen einer
Energiepolitik gegen die die USA ja über
Jahre gewarnt hat die Verstrickungen die
jetzt gut in als Gegenmaßnahmen ausnutzt
sind ja eine Realität eine Realität und
Ablehnung deiner Politik die er über die
Jahre Deutschland betrieben hat im
Gegensatz zu dem Wünschen der Europäern
unter Amerikaner und es ist schwierig
und das höre ich auch im vertraulichen
Gesprächen mit Senatoren und
Abgeordneten wenn sie ihren heimbezirken
Besuchen und Kritik bekommen warum gehen
wir hier mittlerweile sind es 60
Milliarden US-Dollar die bewilligt
worden sind durch den Kongress 17
Milliarden für Waffen warum müssen wir
diese Last tragen und da kommt die
Antwort die Europäer soll mehr machen
warum sollen wir die Rechnung für
Deutschland dann sozusagen Begleichen
der Fehler der letzten Jahren also das
ist auch verständlich aber vielleicht
nur ganz kurz um anzuknüpfen ich darf da
beruhigen erstens dauert der
amerikanischen System und Artikel 2 der
Verfassung ist der amerikanische
Präsident in der Außenpolitik einfach am
Ruder und in der Vergangenheit hat der
Kongress sich auch bei den verlorenen
Kriegen der USA sehr spät erst zu Wort
gemeldet immer bis 64 zum Beispiel kam
die berühmten Golf von donkin Resolution
die wurde erst sieben Jahre später
gekippt die den Präsidenten ermächtigt
hat den Krieg so zu führen wie er wollte
der Irakkrieg ist im März 2003
losgegangen die ersten kritischen
Anhörungen kamen erst 2007 im Frühjahr
und im amerikanischen System im Kongress
sind die Ausschüsse ja sehr mächtig und
die Ausschussvorsitzenden sollten die
Republikaner unter capital die Mehrheit
haben werden ja die sogenannten drei
Mikes sein Mike Turtle Mike kraches und
für die Dienste die Verteidigungspolitik
und die Außenpolitik diese Ausschüsse
leiten werden alle verlässlich
Republikaner der traditionellen Art die
übrigens 2015 schon mitgewirkt haben um
die Autorisierung des Transfers von
legal Waffen an die Ukraine zu
organisieren und auch die Budget der
ermitteln dafür gefunden haben also ich
bin da ziemlich zuversichtlich dass die
Politik der USA hier ziemlich konstant
bleiben wird und beruhigen uns und
trotzdem haben sie ja durchaus
kritisiert das und was die
US-amerikanischen Bürger und auch die
Politiker dokumentieren und kritisieren
Herr Klingbeil warum sollen die
US-Amerikaner für Fehler der vor allen
Dingen deutschen Russlandpolitik zahlen
also ich akzeptiere völlig und das habe
ich hier öffentlich auch erklärt wir
haben in Deutschland falsch
Energiepolitik gemacht dafür nehmen wir
gerade 200 Milliarden in die Hand um das
abzufedern was dort an hohen Kosten
entsteht aber eine falsche
Energiepolitik in Deutschland ist ja
nicht schuld an diesem Krieg an diesem
Krieg ist Putin mit seinen
großmachtsfantasien Schuld der versucht
gerade die Ukraine einzunehmen der Gott
sei Dank daran scheitert mit der
Unterstützung amerikanischer deutscher
viele anderer Waffen auch wir stehen
solidarisch eine Seite Ukraine und in
der Tat wir müssen uns selbst kritisch
fragen was war falsch wir haben uns in
einer einseitige Abhängigkeit begeben
das kostet uns gerade sehr viel Geld das
bringt eine Volkswirtschaft auch ins
Wanken hier und wir müssen gucken was
heißt das an Konsequenzen zum Beispiel
im Umgang mit China aber das da muss ich
widersprechen der Krieg ist begonnen
worden nicht wegen falscher
Energiepolitik die hier eine
Bundesregierung gemacht hat sondern weil
Putin diesen Krieg wollte und da stehen
wir als Europäer mit den Amerikanern
Gott sei Dank solidarisch zusammen wir
unterstützen die u und ich kann an die
USA nur appellieren dass diese
Unterstützung weitergeht das ist eine
eine geopolitische Veränderung die Putin
vorhat die ja auch Auswirkungen auf die
Amerikaner und Tiere aus dem Politik
hätte wenn wir das Zulassen dort müssen
wir weiter im Bündnis zusammenstehen wir
sind Frau malmen die bei der
entscheidenden Frage was das auch für
die wirtschaftliche und die
Handelspolitik bedeutet in einer
tatsächlicher immer komplizierter um
nicht zu sagen furchtbareren Welt und es
ist so dass uns die hohen Energiepreise
und diese Sanktionen natürlich in Europa
in Deutschland viel mehr treffen als sie
die Amerikaner treffen und zurzeit den
Menschen dort das Leben schwer machen
glauben Sie dass das ein Moment ist oder
glauben Sie dass es wirklich nachhaltig
Wettbewerbsvorteile für die
US-Amerikaner gibt
also ich glaube dass das
wirklich eine Zäsur ist was wir gerade
erleben auf vielen Ebenen auf
geopolitischer Ebene wie eben besprochen
wurde aber auch im Nachdenken über
Wirtschaftspolitik wir wissen dass dass
dieser Moment langfristige Folgen haben
wird auf dem Energiemarkt es wird nicht
mehr so wie vorher sein wir werden nicht
mehr zu den Energiepreisen zurückkehren
das können wir aus den Future Preisen ja
jetzt schon ablesen und den serfern wird
es nachhaltige langfristige Nachteile
für die deutsche Industrie geben und
wenn wir da jetzt noch draufsetzen dass
es auch eine Zäsur ist die uns bewusst
gemacht hat dass wir vielleicht zu
leichtfertig Abhängigkeiten eingegangen
sind also da können wir jetzt sowohl
über die USA sprechen aber als auch
Russland in dem Fall und das Thema China
kam ja auch schon immer wieder auf dann
kommt noch in zu dass wir wenn wir das
lösen wollen einen zusätzlichen Schritt
machen müssen der nicht immer leicht
sein wird es schön zu sagen das werden
wir jetzt in Zukunft anders machen sowas
passiert uns nicht mehr bei der
Energiepolitik aber das ist dann im
ersten Moment mal teuer das ist um
ersten Moment mal nicht was der
Unternehmer mag und vielleicht auch was
auf politischer Seite nicht ganz einfach
ist durchzusetzen dass das wird nicht
einfach wir sind
ärmer geworden als Land durch diese
veränderte Situation auf dem
Energiemarkt damit wir uns ganz klar
werden und wenn wir noch weiter gehen
wollen und das adressieren wollen was
gerade angesprochen wird dann werden wir
möglicherweise noch ärmer aber ich
glaube langfristig wird sich auszahlen
damit wir nicht wieder in so einer
Situation an wir müssen noch mal nach
Washington Fragen Peter Rauch Robert
Habeck der Bundeswirtschaftsminister hat
schon sich schon mal beklagt zu welchen
Mondpreisen die US-Amerikaner lng-gas
verkaufen und sich da irgendwie
unsolidarisch zeigen wir wären viel
solidarischer gewesen als die USA in
Sachen Öl in Not waren oder unsere
Solidarität brauchten
würden sie dann sagen dass das ein
weiterer Wettbewerbsvorteil für die
Amerikaner ist
naja also die US-amerikanische Regierung
zur Zeit unternimmt ja alles Mögliche um
international mehr
Energiequellen zu finden aufzusuchen und
Europa zu stützen und auch in den
Weltmarkt etwas zu stabilisieren sind
aber bei der heimischen Produktion
Produktion ziemlich zurückhaltend also
man hat ja schon ein zwiespältiges
Gefühl bei den Amerikaner dass sie bei
der heimischen Produktion vielleicht
wegen den Klimawandel politischen
Dynamiken etwas zurückhaltend agiert
international aber aber aktiv unterwegs
ist letztendlich ist das aber auch eine
Frage von Angebot und Nachfrage und wenn
die Preise zu teuer sind dann müsste man
vielleicht dafür sorgen doch
Regulierungen unter anderem vielleicht
dass es erleichtert zu Hause die
Produktion und so dass die Preise dann
etwas fallen würden aber dass man hier
versucht die Europäer auszunutzen das
würde ich eher bezweifeln wir wollen sie
bezweifeln sie verstehen dass die
Europäer das vollständig anders sehen
was sie sagen es gibt nicht nur
wesentlich günstigere Energiepreise in
den Vereinigten Staaten schon lange so
aber nun auch ein 430 Milliarden Euro
subventionspaket damit werben die USA
tatsächlich europäische Firmen
ab
jeder für sich alle gegen alle ist das
die neue wirtschaftsdoktrin im Westen
das US-Gesetz zur Inflationsbekämpfung
ein 430 Milliarden mega-schutzschirm für
die amerikanische Wirtschaft das
Nachsehen haben die Europäer
wir Konzerns wir sind besorgt über die
Folgen des Inflation reduction Act wir
sollten alles tun um ein wie du mir so
ich dir Szenario oder gar ein
Handelskrieg zu vermeiden
wir brauchen ein kauft europäisch Gesetz
für die USA wir müssen europäische
Produzenten schützen Europäer sind immer
noch zu naiv
erneut wird klar was seit Jahren kein
Geheimnis ist nur dass es Europa und
Deutschland wieder mal unvorbereitet
trifft die
in denen wir uns auf andere
völlig verlassen konnten wir sind ein
Stück vorbei wir Europäer müssen unser
Schicksal wirklich in unserer eigene
Hand nehmen
das war 2017 Angela Merkel Herr Lindner
wird das eine
reindustrialisierung Amerikas auf
Europas kosten was da jetzt auf dem
Tisch liegt und schon mal mit sehr viel
Geld unterstützt
die USA haben jetzt eine Politik
eingeleitet die eigenen heimischen
Industrien mit Geld zu unterstützen
übrigens auch was ja eigentlich zu
begrüßen ist die dekarbonisierung der
Wirtschaft mit Subventionen
voranzutreiben und sie haben
protektionistische Handelsbarrieren
beschlossen von denen ich allerdings
glaube dass das eher gegen die
Volksrepublik China gerichtet ist als
gegen die Europäische Union und deshalb
müssen wir reagieren sie haben das Wort
von Handelskrieg in den Mund genommen
ausgerechnet bei den US-Amerikanern und
haben gesagt wenn wir nicht reden drohe
uns ein Handelskrieg also man liest
Tesla und nashford überlegen jetzt ob
sie ihre batteriestandorte aus
Deutschland weg eben in die Vereinigten
Staaten ich frage mit konkretem Anlass
ja und aus konkretem Anlass habe ich
auch vor einem Handelskrieg gewarnt weil
es ja auch Stimmen in Europa gibt die
jetzt von einem bei European act dass
man nicht stimmen möge nur noch
europäische Produkte kaufen und es gibt
die Überlegung auch Subventionen jetzt
an unsere Unternehmen noch stärker zu
zahlen und auch Handelsbarrieren oder
Zölle in Europa zu beschließen das halte
ich für falsch und
meine Empfehlung an uns ist anders zu
reagieren nämlich einerseits und vor
meinem dia sie haben das eben
dankenswerterweise angesprochen unsere
eigene Wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu
verbessern wenn die USA gute
Standortbedingungen bieten dann wird man
einem privaten Investor nicht verbieten
können dahin zu gehen weil der wird sich
sagen wo habe ich die besten Bedingungen
das verweist auf uns also Planungs und
Genehmigungsverfahren Infrastruktur
digitale öffentliche Verwaltung
Einwanderungsgesetz bezahlbare Energie
und so weiter und so fort ich füge hinzu
auch ein wettbewerbsfähiges Steuerrecht
das können wir tun um unsere
Standortbedingungen zu verbessern und
auf der anderen Seite
Frau Illner nicht dieses
wie du mir so ich dir
die USA so habe ich formuliert genau
Tipp for Ted sagt man auch wie machen
das also machen wir das sondern mein Rad
an uns ist lasst uns erstmal sprechen
wisst ihr beiden Administrationen dass
das auslöst dass das nicht nur ein
Effekt hat auf China sondern auch auf
uns welche Möglichkeiten von Ausnahmen
gibt es und ich bin mal sehr
ambitioniert die amerikanische
Finanzministerin Janet Jane sprach
unlängst von einem friendshoring und sie
meint damit in meinen Worten gesagt dass
wertepartner auch bevorzugte
Handelspartner sein könnten mein Rat ist
lassen wir uns die doch beim Wort nehmen
und sagen okay wir haben eine gemeinsame
Herausforderung die heißt Volksrepublik
China wir haben gemeinsame Werte das
beweisen wir gerade in der Ukraine dass
wir diesen Werten
nicht nur am Sonntag Preisen sondern
auch Taten folgen lassen lasst uns jetzt
beim Handel auch statt gegeneinander
miteinander an Wohlstand haben wir schon
wieder bei ttip und einem
Handelsabkommen dass eine unglaubliche
Geschichte hat die Runde ist eröffnet
Herr kling weil sie erklären und sind
die Franzosen mutige ist Herr macron
mutiger wenn er sagt wir müssen jetzt
endlich europäische Antwort nicht jedes
Land für sich und so sondern wir setzen
jetzt als Europäer auf unsere Industrie
auf unsere Kerne und ja sind einfach
ich finde die macron Äußerungen
sozusagen von dem Handelskrieg und bi
European finde ich falsch das wollen wir
das kriegt war Herr Lindner er hat das
er hat das als Szenario in den Raum
gestellt hat aber nicht gesagt dass er
das will wenn Interview verliert von
Bruno Lema die Woche angucke dann sind
die Franzosen dort deutlich schärfer in
der Wortwahl und ich halte das für
falsch weil ich auch glaube ich müssen
genau gucken wie wir mit
Amerikanern
aber in der Tat für mich geht es auch
drum sich bewusst zu machen was wir
eigentlich mit 27 europäischen Staaten
alles erreichen können das ist eine
wahnsinnige Marktmacht die da ist ja wir
kriegen nicht mal eine kapitalmarktunion
gerade hin es gibt ja auch genug die
investieren würden in Europa ja da muss
man aber gute Bedingungen für schaffen
wenn wir es schaffen konsequent die
Erneuerbaren auszubauen da
Geschäftsmodelle draus machen wenn wir
es in Deutschland hinkriegen
planungsgenehmigungsverfahren was wir in
der Regierung ja gerade schon tun da
haben wir im ersten Jahr viel erreicht
wenn Einwanderung ist halt Stichwort
genannt worden so wenn wir dieses
Bewusstsein haben dass wir Europa stark
positionieren müssen USA auf der einen
Seite Schiene auf der anderen aber das
ist darum jetzt die nächsten fünf bis
zehn Jahre geht dann glaube ich kann das
hier ein wunderbarer Standort werden
auch für Investitionen aber dieses
Bewusstsein muss da sein und die
Auseinandersetzung damit die fängt ja
jetzt an dann fangen wir gleich die
schlauen Frauen wir sind jetzt ja
eigentlich schon mitten in einem
Subventionswettlauf
also nochmal die Frage sind die
Franzosen mutige oder benutzen sie
einfach nur die kräftigeren Worte
sollten wir uns als Europäer nicht
verbünden schauen jetzt nicht alle
europäischen Regierungen wie sie ihre
Industrien schützen und zwar jedes für
sich also ich finde protektionistische
Reflexe nicht mutig muss ich sagen ich
halte sie auch für falsch ich halte das
auch wenn man es zu Ende denkt für
völlig falsch Herr Lindner hat
wertepartner angesprochen ich meine wenn
man mal einen Schritt zurücktritt und
auf die globale Lage schaut dann haben
wir
ein ein systemrivalität mit China
worüber wenn er sprechen wollen wir
haben
ein Aggressor Russland ja wir haben alle
möglichen anderen Länder die die
schwierig sind und wir haben Europa und
Amerika und und Kanada also den den
nordamerikanischen Raum mit denen wir
Differenzen in manchen Punkten haben
aber in denen man ja im Großen und
Ganzen im Wertesystem auch übrigens in
der Idee des Freihandels an sich
übereinstimmt und deswegen wäre es
gerade zu absurd über den Atlantik
Mauern aufzubauen und sich dagegen seit
das Leben schwer zu machen da ich glaube
das haben sie auch gesagt ich will es
mir jetzt nicht zu eigen machen da
gibt's nur Verlierer wenn ich sie
richtig machen so das ist völlig richtig
in dem Punkt der Linda völlig Recht so
jetzt wird das Problem ist natürlich
dass uns die
Handelspolitik die nicht Handelspolitik
der vergangenen Jahre auf die Füße fällt
und der Präsident Obama hätte es die
Chance gegeben ein ttip zu verhandeln
ein Freihandelsabkommen zwischen den USA
und Europa warum hat es nicht geklappt
vor allem aus Deutschland kam damals der
Widerstand
sogenannte chlorhuhn nein das war unter
Obama und Obama der war bereits zu
verhandeln da kam der Widerstand das
angebliche chlorhuhn die angeblich
schrecklichen Schiedsgerichte eine
vollkommen heuchlerische Position war
das schon damals weil Deutschland seit
nach vorne schauen
man muss ja also ehrlich gesagt wenn die
Russland wenn der wenn die wenn das
Problem mit Russland uns eins lädt ist
ja aus der aus den Fehlern der
Vergangenheit lernen und da muss man sie
auch mal angucken und benennen weil es
ja auch in ihrer Koalition noch genügend
freihandelskritiker begegner gibt muss
man ja sagen weniger in der ja sie haben
es auf den Weg gemacht aber auch da ist
es immer noch nicht ratifiziert das ist
glaube ich zwei 17 abgeschlossen worden
ich meine was für eine Wirkung hat das
auch auf Kanada dass man immer und auch
auf die Amerikaner immer wieder den mit
Misstrauen begegnet im Sommer ist noch
verhandelt worden ein Zusatz
agreement auf Wunsch Deutschlands mit
Kanada dass man sich
das deutsche das die Kanadier zusichern
mussten dass dieses investitionskapitel
nicht missbräuchlich verwendet wird ja
also das hat das hat Europa das hat
insbesondere die Bundesregierung
erwartet von den kanadien so ein
Zugeständnis wo man sich fragt was für
eine Botschaft sendet man da das ist
eine Botschaft des Misstrauens und
ehrlich gesagt also ich halte das in
dieser Situation wirklich für fatal und
da wäre es doch mal ein Zeichen und da
hat glaube ich die Unionsfraktion schon
mehrfach die zweite und dritte Lesung
der Ratifikation von ceta angesetzt ist
jedes Mal verschoben worden sie auch mal
ein Zeichen zumindest dass die Kanadier
wollen ja noch ja zumindest das
durchzuziehen und tietet das werden sie
besser beurteilen können aber ich sehe
aus den anderen von den Amerikanern
derzeit überhaupt gar keine
keine Vorstöße dieses diese Verhandlung
noch mal aufzunehmen aber da würde ich
sagen Moment also was die Union angeht
vier Jahre haben die ttip haben die ceta
nicht ratifiziert wir machen es jetzt
ist ja kein Geheimnis dass es innerhalb
der Bundesregierung unterschiedliche
Nuancen gibt aus der SPD höre ich
Stimmen die einen neuen Anlauf für
transatlantischen Freihandel wollen
unsere Kolleginnen und Kollegen von den
Grünen haben noch
paarungsvermögen
reflexionsbedarf aber ich will gerne
nach vorne gerichtet sagen Sie haben
recht das vor dem gegenwärtigen
Hintergrund das Europa wenig
wettbewerbsfähig ist vielleicht auch
nicht immer so einheitlich auftritt wie
es sein sollte dass der Appetit in
Washington zu sagen das was schon einmal
gescheitert ist nehmen wir noch einmal
auf der ist gering aber das sollte uns
ja nicht abhalten davon dass diesmal wir
die Initiative ergreifen als Europäer
und sagen wir haben jetzt in einer neuen
Weltlage unsere Prioritäten sortiert die
Fehler von ttip werden wenn nicht
wiederholen vielleicht wird auch der
Umfang der damals gedacht worden ist
jetzt gar nicht auf den Tisch gelegt
aber es ist jedenfalls besser zu
sprechen und zu schauen was geht als
überhaupt gar keine Ambition zu
entwickeln in welcher Welt sie in
welcher Weltsituation überhaupt wir
haben es ja gerade gesagt in welcher
Weltsituation überhaupt sollten die
liberalen Demokratien eigentlich enger
kooperieren wenn ich so und das ist ein
guter Gedanke und ich habe mir trotzdem
meine Frage gemerkt und sage der
subventionswettbewerb ist ja längst im
Gange
unterstützt die deutsche Regierung nicht
auch nach Kräften die deutsche
Wirtschaft weil sie muss
ja also man muss ein bisschen vorsichtig
sein die deutsche Regierung kann das
nicht so locker flockig tun wie die
Amerikaner die ist nämlich eingebunden
in eine EU muss dazu Regeln gibt und an
die müssen wir uns halten und bei allen
möglichen Beschlüssen auch in aller in
letzter Zeit muss man halt immer nach
Brüssel gehen und schauen ob das alles
auch durchzukriegen ist ist also nicht
einfacher für uns nicht einfach für uns
und das macht es dann natürlich so ein
bisschen schwierig sich anzugucken wie
die USA dann ihren Inflation reduction
Act beschließen können und diese ganzen
inflationsakt dahinter stehen diese 430
oder das Gesetz stehen diese 430
Milliarden Entschuldigung genau und
trotzdem würde ich sagen das was ich
eigentlich von allen gesagt wurde dass
jetzt erstmal die Situation durch Dialog
anzugehen der richtige Weg ist weil die
USA halten Land ist mit dem wir eine
lange Beziehung haben die in vieler
Hinsicht nun funktioniert hat wichtiger
Partner ist es ist auch ein Partner von
dem wir auch schon gewisse Abhängigkeit
haben nicht so schlimm wie China wo es
gibt so eine eu-index von Produkten bei
eine hohe Abhängigkeit hat als für
Deutschland mit 45 Prozent China dabei
also Produkte aber nicht gut
substituieren und diversifizieren kann
aber auch mit 15 Prozent die USA weit
über dem EU-Durchschnitt also wir
sollten das schon vorsichtig sein und
wir sollten auch klar uns darüber sein
da bin ich vielleicht etwas kühle
Ökonomen ja dass solche Gespräche wo man
die anderen informiert welche Probleme
wir denn hier in Europa mit dem Akt
haben wahrscheinlich nicht so weit
kommen führen werden Dankeschön wenn man
nicht in der Hinterhand hat naja wir
wollen alle kein Handelskrieg aber es
gibt schon gewisse Sachen die wir machen
könnten das wäre sehr traurig und als
Europäer zusammen da aufzutreten ist
glaube ich sehr sehr gut und sich klar
zu sein wir können auch das gesamte
Spektrum es handelsinstrumentarium zu
nutzen vielleicht bieten wir sogar
Vorteile an genau wir können ja wir
können ja sagen wir können drohen wir
reagieren wir können aber auch sagen wir
bieten einen Vorteil ihr habt bestimmte
Spezialisierungen die wir übrigens auch
brauchen also öffnen wir unsere Märkte
und übrigens wir können zum Beispiel
ganz gut Autos genau aber
können trotzdem vornehmen dir wir können
ja sagen es ist eben dieses gemeinsame
europäische auftreten leider nicht da es
ist eigentlich noch viel komplizierter
man unterstellt ja den deutschen dass
sie mit einem einen größeren Egoismus
unterwegs sind egal ob es jetzt der
doppelwumms ist oder ob es diese
besonderen china-beziehungen sind
unterstellt man ja ausgerechnet den
Deutschen in ihren Intentionen dass wir
auch bei German sagen und nicht nur die
Amerikaner bei American ja das ist ja
aber es ist gerade in Bezug auf Amerika
sehr sehr schade weil wenn du mal als
europäischer Binnenmarkt also Ansammlung
von 27 Staaten vielleicht plus noch da
sehr viel stärker auftreten können und
da jetzt Deutschland so herauszuzufuppen
aus einer Mischung zwischen vielleicht
ein gewisser Neid dass wir uns das halt
leisten können so mit den Problemen
umzugehen es ist nun mal so dass wir
eine starke Wirtschaftskraft sind ja
überproportional zu unserer Bevölkerung
da da spielt halt viel mit ich ich
möchte trotzdem sagen dass das
solidarische vorgehen dass wir unserem
Jahresgutachten immer wieder betont
haben dieses Jahr als Wirtschaftsweise
wirklich gerade gegenüber den USA uns
nur helfen kann also da jetzt mal die
Situation der Stunde wie sie eben gesagt
haben zu nutzen dass wir uns wirklich
zusammenraufen und so weit wie möglich
eine gemeinsame
Außenwirtschaftspolitik in der Hinsicht
zu betreiben versuchen ist ist extrem
angesagt das ist bei anderen Ländern
noch viel schwieriger also China ist ja
ständig schon die ganze Zeit im Raum da
ist es sehr viel schwieriger als
gemeinsames Europa aufzutreten unter
anderem weil wir halt oder viele Länder
einschließlich Deutschland in einiger
Hinsicht blauäugig gewesen sind einige
mehr als andere und da ist es wird es
noch komplizierter sein alle an einen
Tisch zu kommen
eine Sache ist mir wichtig ich bin auch
dafür dass wir mit den Amerikanern genau
über diese Frage Handel reden ob das
jetzt ttip ist ob das was Neues ist aber
ich glaube wir müssen gucken wie wir da
gemeinsam zusammenkommen können trotzdem
müssen wir uns in Deutschland in Europa
genau angucken was die Amerikaner dort
an staatlicher
Investitionspolitik Industriepolitik
gerade machen und wir müssen auch
Konsequenzen daraus ziehen Stichwort
aktive Industriepolitik ja ich mein
selbst der BDI fordert das mittlerweile
dass der Staat in Deutschland dort eine
aktive Rolle einnimmt und das ist ja an
ganz vielen Stellen noch das was wir in
der Koalition Vorhaben und wo wir gute
Dinge auch im Koalitionsvertrag um
eingeschrieben haben zweiter Punkt aber
sich sogar nach Peter Altmaier offen
zweiter Punkt das will ich schon sagen
was Europa angeht sie haben jetzt gerade
diese Kritik die wir bekommen haben in
den letzten Wochen ich glaube da muss
man die Kirche ein bisschen im Dorf
lassen alle europäischen Länder machen
gerade etwas um die Energiepreise nach
unten zu drücken natürlich ist die
Erwartung natürlich ist die Erwartung an
Deutschland dass man auch europäisches
macht aber es ist doch im Interesse
aller europäischen Länder dass wir hier
die industriestabilisieren dass wir hier
in Deutschland die Arbeitsplätze sichern
dass die nicht in die USA abwandert das
ist ein gemeinsames europäisches
Interesse und deswegen glaube ich war
die Kritik da am Anfang stark überzogen
konnte auch geklärt werden und
mittlerweile hat sich das ja auch ein
bisschen
europäischen Partnern bekommen
Rosen haben gesagt Deutschland darf sich
nicht isolieren so ähnlich war es glaube
ich oder damals na ja es ist abgeräumt
aber man fragt sie natürlich warum muss
es überhaupt so weit kommen ehrlich
gesagt also warum begibt man sich in
eine Lage als Deutschland also ein
Doppelpunkt zu beschließen ganz ehrlich
gesagt falsch in einer Krisensituation
immer Entschuldigung gleich ist er dran
in einer Krisensituation immer sofort
den nationalen Fokus diese Reflexe zu
bekommen dass man erstmal sozusagen
Germany first das kann doch nicht
ehrlich gesagt wenn man sich anschaut
die großen Krisen der vergangenen Jahre
sehen wir das Phänomen immer wenn die
Krise wenn die Ängste größer werden
guckt man erstmal auf das eigene Land
das haben wir bei der Impfstoff
Besorgung gesehen wo es keine
europäische erst keine europäische
Lösung gibt das haben wir in anderen
Punkten gesehen und das haben wir auch
jetzt gesehen die deutschen kriegen
Angst wie bezahlen wir unsere Rechnung
dann macht man erstmal ein eigenes Paket
das ist ja okay aber dann zumindest mal
kommunizieren das wäre doch was gewesen
man hätte es doch zumindest das ist
durch ihre Situationen hätte zu
verhindern können indem man einmal
angerufen hätte aber das Christian
Lindner Robert Habeck und Olaf Scholz
sich auf ein 200 Milliarden Paket
einigen um die Energiepreise runter zu
drücken und dafür zu sorgen dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und die
Unternehmen die Rechnung bezahlen und
das ist doch der Moment in dem es
öffentlich wird und man ruft doch nicht
vorher bei den europäischen Partnern an
sondern erstmal einigt man sich in der
Koalition das ist passiert und dann sind
die Partner eingebunden worden und das
ist noch mal im europäischen Interesse
dass wir hier die Industriearbeitsplätze
Sichern von Solidarität und wenn
sozusagen deutsche Presse die ich ja
immer hochhalte dass er weiß als die
französische Regierung dann finde ich
dass es ein Problem ja Sie können auch
sonst vieles geheim halten und genau
dass er die französische Regierung
ausgedrückt wir wollen unbedingt noch
mal nach Washington und Peter rauf
Fragen nach eben diesem Egoismus
ja ich wollte nur anknüpfen aus Sicht
Washington zwei wir gerade bei der
Kritik sind es geht nicht nur um die
europäische Kritik wie spielen sie auch
von zum Beispiel den Koreanern und den
Japanern und ich würde raten dass die
Europäer sich zusammensetzen mit den
anderen demokratischen Bündnis Partnern
die hier mit der Subventionen nicht
gerade glücklich sind weil die E-Autos
angesprochen worden sind in den USA
haben wir weder die Kapazitäten
Fähigkeit die sie zu erstellen noch die
weder noch die Rohstoffe die für die
Batterien notwendig sind also es ist
eine ziemlich lange Rollbahn bevor das
Flugzeug hier abheben ich glaube dass
man bei der Implementation durch
Gespräche einiges ausbügeln mit noch
können ja da sind sie schon wieder der
Moderator und hier ernten hier
Kopfnicken wenn wir heraus aber uns auch
noch mal anschauen was die US-Amerikaner
machen auch gegenüber dann automatisch
den Europäern sie haben Sanktionen gegen
Russland Sanktionen gegen Iran
Sanktionen gegen China wo darf man
Rohstoffe kaufen wem darf man Mikrochips
verkaufen oder liefern hat irgendjemand
also das ist ja eine Form von
Protektionismus oder von geopolitischem
Wirtschaften
dass man irgendwie nicht mit dem
Mutterland des Kapitalismus
zusammenbringt vielleicht kann ich so
sagen
ja wir sind jetzt in einer Rivalität das
Systeme die drei Länder die Sie gerade
genannt haben sind nicht gerade jetzt
liberale Demokratien die sich unbedingt
positiv auf auf der Weltbühne Benehmen
die Iraner sind aktiv daran beteiligt
sogar die Ostflanke der NATO durch
iranische Drohnen die sie Russland
überliefert haben anzugreifen die
Chinesen sind mit Diebstahl des
geistigen Eigentums regelmäßig unterwegs
und über Russland brauchen wir gar nicht
sprechen was sie zurzeit machen die
gefährden die gesamte sicherheitsordnung
also ja mit Europa mit anderen Ländern
sieht man hier die Möglichkeit für
Freihandel und wir haben alle unsere
Schwächen also wenn man zum Beispiel die
Agrarpolitik Europas unter die Lupe
nimmt der fließen teilweise mehr Gelder
von Brüssel an heimischen Bauernhöfe wie
die für die Produkte überhaupt verdienen
also ja das heißt dann ist ein wichtiger
Bestandteil der französischen Identität
weil früher mal dran zitiert worden ist
aber wenn die Amerikaner so etwas machen
heißt es amerikanischer Egoismus wir
haben alle Schwächen es sind aber Teil
eines breiteren liberalen demokratischen
Systems möchten ungefähr die gleiche
Weltordnung aufrechterhalten und
gewährleisten und ich glaube man muss
diese Stolpersteine ausräumen sondern
dass wir unsere wahre Konfrontation da
angehen können und das ist das Problem
dass die Chinesen da uns mehr oder
weniger bieten wir sind hier nur auch in
der Situation uns zu fragen ob das
Länder sind die sie da Listen die
gegebenenfalls den US-Amerikanern auch
nicht so viel bedeuten oder nicht so
schaden können warum reden wir nicht in
gleicher Schärfe über Saudi-Arabien oder
Katar
bei Saudi-Arabien sich mehr oder weniger
der internationalen Ordnung anpasst sie
versuchen nicht die gesamten nahe
Ostregion zu destabilisieren wie der
Iran zum Beispiel wir haben auch hohe
Kosten die wir tragen in unserer
Venezuela Politik das ist direkt in
unserer Nachbarschaft ein Land das
Massiv auch Öl an die USA geliefert hat
Matura hat dann das unternommen was
unternommen hat die Amerikaner haben
darauf reagiert war für uns auch nicht
gerade einfach also ich glaube die hier
geht's um das Zwischenspiel oder
Zusammenspiel zwischen einerseits Werte
einerseits die Ordnung schätzen und die
andere Zeit halt die wirtschaftliche
Interessen und dieses dieses
Gleichgewicht diese Abwägung die ist
nicht immer einfach aber wir versuchen
es zumindest wir sind noch mal bei der
Frage was man eigentlich jetzt tut und
wie man es klug tut um dieser multikrise
etwas entgegenzusetzen Herr Lindner und
das sind in allererster Linie Ausgaben
des Staates es sind auch staatliche
Ausgaben für die Bürger ist in
staatliche Ausgaben für die Industrie
für einzeln Wirtschaftsunternehmen und
das ist begründbar und sicherlich gut so
weil sie natürlich irgendwie der
Bevölkerung dieses Landes auch
verpflichtet sind an welcher Stelle kann
man beginnen dass europäisch mit der
Regierung macron zu denken und irgendwie
in die Tat umzusetzen ich kann ja nicht
weiter so gehen dass wir uns mit einem
der wichtigsten Verbündeten in Europa so
auf offener Bühne streiten wie sonst
eigentlich nur sie haben eine ganz enge
Partnerschaft und Freundschaft mit
Frankreich die historisch gewachsen und
die wird jeden Tag gelebt also mit
meinem französischen Amtskollegen habe
ich
jeden Tag also jeden Tag zu tun tauscht
mir eine Nachricht aus telefonieren also
wirklich jeden Tag eben diesen Zeiten
und wir werden das auch noch weiter
intensivieren denn wir haben über den
Tag und diese Krise hinaus große
Gestaltungsaufgaben Lars Klingbeil eben
angesprochen die kapitalmarktunion
übersetzt es kann eben nicht nur Geld
vom Staat sein mit dem wir die
Erneuerung bewirtschaften und erreichen
sondern wir brauchen eben auch privates
Kapital damit unternehmerische Chancen
und wirtschaftliche Erneuerung gelingen
und das ist in dem europäischen
Binnenmarkt leichter möglich also solche
Projekte werden natürlich dann am besten
angeschoben wenn es auch ein paar gibt
die Ideen einbringen gesagt ganz offen
ich bin kein Freund des Wortes
Führungsmacht weil das sehr stark eine
Singularität Deutschlands ausdrücken
könnte ich weiß es nicht so gemeint aber
es könnte so missverstanden werden und
ich würde eher von einer strategischen
Verantwortung Deutschlands sprechen die
sich darin zeigt dass wir in Europa die
unterschiedlichen Akteure
zusammenbringen das größte Problem
Europas wenn ich das so sagen darf ist
ja nicht das deutsch-französische
Verhältnis sondern wir haben eben ein
paar andere Mitglieder der Wirtschafts-
und Währungsunion und der Europäischen
Union die in ganz grundlegenden sagen
zum Beispiel des Rechtsstaats schon
anders aufgestellt sind und solcherlei
grundlegende Unterschiede gibt zwischen
Paris und Berlin nicht ich habe nicht
ohne Grund gefragt wie Sie sich denken
meine nächste Frage ist warum hat Olaf
Scholz auf seine tolle Reise nach Peking
immer nur immer kommen nicht mitgenommen
da hätte man doch schon mal großartig
ein Zeichen zeigen können oder setzen
können was für ein großer und wichtiger
verbundmand darstellt ich weiß nicht ob
das überhaupt jetzt zur Diskussion
gestanden hätte weiß zum Beispiel dass
Emanuel macron
anfangen dezember in Washington ist und
nach meiner Information fährt er als
staatsschef auch alleine dort hin weil
es auch bilaterale Beziehungen gibt aber
jetzt nach dem Besuch von Olaf Scholz in
Peking kann es ja überhaupt gar kein
Zweifel geben wie Deutschland
positioniert ist der Bundeskanzler hat
klarer denn je über Fragen von
Völkerrecht und Menschenrechten
gesprochen
das ist allerdings auch wie ich finde
nachvollziehbar und selbstverständlich
dass man auch über die wirtschaftlichen
Beziehungen spricht sie hat zu Recht
gesagt worden dass das Verhältnis
zwischen Deutschland und Europa
einerseits und andererseits China
hochkomplex ist es ist ein systemischer
Rivale es ist ein Konkurrenz wenn es
beispielsweise um Einfluss in Afrika
geht aber es ist eben auch unser
Gegenüber im Handel mit der gegenwärtig
noch wie ich finde gefährlichen Ballung
von Risiken in einem Binnenmarkt das
kann man auch nicht sofort aufheben also
wir müssen Anfragen Menschenrechte
Völkerrecht arbeiten und sehr kritisch
mit China sprechen ich mache das als
Finanzminister übrigens bei der Frage
der Verschuldung von Schwellen und
Entwicklungsländern wo China seiner
Verantwortung nicht gerecht wird ist
einer der größten Gläubiger weltweit wir
müssen es tun indem wir eine Antwort
geben auf die systemische
Herausforderung indem wir nämlich
Demokratie und Rechtsstaat und
Marktwirtschaft verteidigen und wir
müssen im Handel uns aus der
Abhängigkeit lösen nicht indem wir der
deutschen Wirtschaft sagen Haut da ab
das wäre gefährlich sondern indem wir
andere Weltregionen attraktiver machen
indem wir Handelsbarrieren senken wir
haben die asia-staaten also sehr
dynamisch wachsende asiatische Staaten
wir haben natürlich Kanada und die USA
es hat in Brasilien gerade ein
Regierungswechsel gegeben das eröffnet
auch neue Optionen ich könnte das weiter
fortsetzen also man sollte nicht sagen
raus aus China sondern anderes wichtiger
und und leichter im Handel machen wir
sind das war jetzt das große Bild wir
sind bei ganz konkreten Fragen Frau im
sie helfen uns Diskussion um den Verkauf
eines Teiles des Hamburger Hafens hat
Deutschland glaube ich so verfolgt wie
wenig andere es in den letzten sieben
Tagen der Deal ist mit Nord Stream 2
verglichen worden hat Deutschland
sich da jetzt schon wieder auf den
Sonderweg gemacht in Bezug auf
es war natürlich äußerst interessant
dass jetzt so eine relativ kleine
Beteiligung und im Hafen zu seiner
großen Diskussion geführt hat wo andere
helfen in Europa inzwischen komplett in
chinesischer sind aber das war natürlich
der Situation der Stunde geschuldet wir
hatten da alle so Flashbacks oh schon
wieder so eine Abhängigkeit die gerade
aufgebaut wird und das fand ich
eigentlich sehr sehr gut also ich fand
es sehr sehr gut dass wir jetzt wo wir
gerade die Situation mit Russland der
Energie Abhängigkeit durchlebt haben und
sagen das lässt mich vielleicht
verallgemeinern und das ist vielleicht
auch anwendbar auf diese Situation und
dann nehmen wir das jetzt mal zum Anlass
um uns alle sehr darüber aufzuregen und
wenn das jetzt so bleibt dass es sowohl
in der Politik als auch ganz wichtig auf
privater Seite bei den Unternehmen mehr
im Kopf ist dass das zu vermeiden ist
das wäre extrem gut für Deutschland denn
sicherlich wollen wir den Handel mit
China jetzt nicht abbrechen aber immer
mal überlegen bin ich diversifiziert
genug soll ich nicht wie die Japaner das
machen ne China Plasma Politik haben wo
ich eben nicht immer darum kümmere das
ist eine substituierte
geben könnte das ist halt ganz wichtig
und da bin ich der Hamburger
hafen-diskussion sehr dankbar dass sie
in die Welt kam vor Borowski gleich ist
Herr klingball dran ich wollte ein Linda
in einem Punkt widersprechen und zwar
das ist Olaf Scholz mit seiner
China-Reise so ein klares Signal gesetzt
hätte der Tweet danach er hat getwittert
Vertrauen und Verlässlichkeit sind Werte
die sowohl China als auch Deutschland
teilen also man ich ich weiß nicht wie
sie auf Twitter ja das sollen sie mal
tun wenn der Kanzler filtert also ich
weiß nicht wie man aus dieser Reise in
der er jetzt sicher öffentlich das ich
werfe ihm das jetzt nicht vor aber ich
frage mich einfach wie sie zum Ergebnis
kommen dass diese Reise nun ein klares
Signal war dass Sie dass Deutschland
auch in den Blick auf China eine
Zeitenwende vollzogen hat und der ganze
Airbus war voller deutscher Unternehmer
was ich auch nicht kritisiere ich will
nur sagen ich habe diesen Besuch und
auch Olaf Scholz Verhalten in der
hafenfrage der ja weniger
Problembewusstsein hat würde ich jetzt
mal sagen als andere Bakterien der
Bundesregierung nicht wahrgenommen bei
Olaf Scholz persönlich als Kanzler nicht
wahrgenommen dass das ein
eindeutiger
Scholz oder der Bundeskanzler verteidigt
werden muss machen sie ich würde sagen
zwei Sätze also natürlich verstehe ich
welchen Maßstab sie anlegen verstehe ich
ich würde empfehlen den Vergleich mit
der Vorgängerin und nichts gegen Frau
Merkels war eine andere Zeit es geht
jetzt gar nicht darum zurückzuschauen
nur der Bundeskanzler jetzt im Jahr 2022
hat die Gespräche und auch seine
öffentliche Kommunikation nicht begonnen
mit den Wirtschaftsbeziehungen sondern
mit Fragen Menschenrechte Völkerrecht
und dem klaren Klaren sind dabei ist die
Frage aber das ist da also
Entschuldigung dass man die deutschen
Interessen auch in wirtschaftlicher
Hinsicht vertritt ich würde Ihnen hier
kritisieren den Bundeskanzler wenn er
die nicht aufgenommen hätte aber klar
ist auch Menschenrechte Völkerrecht und
die Haltung und die Haltung zu Russland
das stand im Zentrum aber völlig richtig
also da würde ich immer Verantwortung
für übernehmen völlig richtig dass wir
auch die Wirtschaftsbeziehungen im Blick
behalten ich meine wovon leben wir wir
sind Exploration Russland haben wir gar
nicht mit drin gehabt also dass der
Bundeskanzler ein ganz wichtigen
diplomatischen Erfolg erzielt hat was
das Verhalten Chinas und die
Positionierung Chinas in der
russlandfrage im ukrainekrieg angeht da
haben wir viele gar nicht mit gerechnet
aber das war der größte Gewinn dieser
Reise ein deutliches Signal auch was
schwieriger Russland gesendet hat
wir können aber die Chinesen nicht an
die Seite drängen wenn es um die Frage
Russland und Ukraine Krieg geht das ist
eine der wichtigsten Nationen wenn es
darum geht auch diesen Krieg zu beenden
und das war ein kompletter Erfolg dieser
Reise Olaf Scholz hat das Thema
Menschenrecht in aller Deutlichkeit
angesprochen und die Kritik die ich in
den Tagen davor erlebt habe die war
teilweise schon absurd muss ich
Bundeskanzler dahinfährt dass er mit dem
chinesischen Staatspräsidenten redet das
war wichtig dass er die Wirtschaft mit
dabei hat wenn wir gerade und ich finde
stimmen völlig zu es war richtig dass am
Beispiel Hamburger Hafen diese Debatte
gestartet ist wir müssen die jetzt auch
zu klaren Beschlüssen für das braucht
klare Strategien es braucht klare
Festlegung in welchen Bereichen die
Chinesen draußen bleiben wo wir unsere
Abhängigkeiten und zu sagen und zu sagen
da nehme ich die deutsche Wirtschaft mit
weil ich die verantwortlich einbinde in
diesen Diskurs also ich finde wirklich
an dieser Reise hat sich gezeigt wir
hatten vorher aufgeregte Debatten und
die haben sich danach die Frage warum
war Emmanuel macron nicht an seiner
Seite und musste es war der
Antrittsbesuch genau und wenn es um die
Menschenrechte und um eine zukünftige
strategische Aufstellung der Europäer
oder Deutschlands gegenüber China es
geht warum geht er da alleine mit einer
Wirtschaftsdelegation hin also nochmal
es war der Antrittsbesuch des
Bundeskanzlers der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland beim chinesischen
Staatspräsidenten und Antrittsbesuche
macht man erstmal so wie die jetzt
gemacht wurden auch in der politischen
Deutlichkeit es gab ein klares Signal
gegenüber Russland das war wichtig und
ich weiß gar nicht ob es überhaupt
irgendwo mal gedacht gab dass man diese
Besuche zusammen macht oder ob das
wieder eine Diskussion ist die wir in
Deutschland führen und die gar keinen
realen bestimmte das weiß es nicht diese
Bundesregierung hat ja aber Frau
bogowski sich vorgenommen gemeinsam
unter den drei Ampel Koalitionären eine
chinastrategie zu erarbeiten die ist
noch nicht fertig und sollte ein
Bundeskanzler Reisen bevor die fertig
ist weil Herr Scholz wurde sowohl von
Annalena baerbock als auch von ihnen
kritisiert Herr Lindner dafür aber nicht
für die Reise ich habe auch nicht Olaf
Scholz als Person kritisiert sondern ich
habe in der Tat die Entscheidung in
Hamburg problematisiert aus einer
Vielzahl von Gründen und deshalb ja wir
haben ja dann gesprochen dass allerdings
nicht Olaf Scholz zuständig sondern
dieser Fragen werden im
Wirtschaftsministerium
vorbereitet und wir sind ja dann zu
einem verantwortbaren Ergebnis gekommen
das muss man ja auch noch mal in
Erinnerung rufen es handelt sich um die
Reinigung an einem an einer Gesellschaft
die einen Pachtvertrag hat kein Eigentum
zeitlich befristet für ein Teil des
Hamburger Hafens und die Beteiligung an
dieser Gesellschaft ist nicht
beherrschend also unter 25 Prozent da
würde ich sagen das ist verantwortbar
dass diese Entscheidung ausgerechnet im
Zusammenhang mit dem Parteitag der
Kommunistischen Partei in die
Öffentlichkeit kommt wo wir noch mal die
Hegemonie und die die marxistisch
marxistische Grundhaltung dieser Partei
noch mal vor Augen geführt bekommen
haben das ist ausgesprochen unglücklich
und falsch aber die Entscheidung selbst
ist verantwortbar hat aber Konsequenzen
zum einen für die china-strategie an der
die Bundesregierung arbeitet das kann
man nicht übers Knie brechen das ist
noch kein Jahr mehr wirklich nicht das
ist sehr kompliziert sehr komplex und
soll kein Schnellschuss sein wunderbar
ausgerechnet
ja es hängen hunderttausende
Arbeitsplätze daran nicht irgendwelche
Gewinne von DAX-Konzern sondern 100.000
Arbeitsplätze denken Sie an die deutsche
Automobilbranche wo verkaufen die
eigentlich ihre Premium Produkte in
Luxemburg in Liechtenstein so 40 Prozent
ja und also china-strategie und wir
werden unser
Außenwirtschaftsrecht verändern also zum
Beispiel ist mein Vorschlag das
zukünftig wenn es ein Unternehmen gibt
bei dem es Zweifel gibt ob unsere
Sicherheitsinteressen berührt sind dass
dort nicht das Kabinett mehrheitlich
widersprechen muss sondern das Kabinett
sollte einstimmig zustimmen müssen dass
ein solches Unternehmen verkauft werden
darf oder will also will also die Hürde
erhöhen damit das klarer wird bei
Entschuldigung sie wollen es reagieren
dass also ich glaube beides ist wichtig
dass jetzt etwas passiert und zwar
möglichst schnell dass sozusagen wir in
der Öffentlichkeit den Druck
aufrechterhalten ist gut dass sie gute
Gründe haben dass nicht noch nie zu
brechen es ist auch gut ich wollte aber
in einer Hinsicht vielleicht ein klein
bisschen weitergehen als zum Beispiel
diese Idee des frenchoring die
generieren immer vertritt von der ich
ein großer Fan bin ehemalige Kollegin
von mir aber nur sich auf frenchoring zu
stützen ja so wichtig ist ist die
Allianzen jetzt aufzubauen und das zu
benutzen als Teil des Instrumentals
könnte manchmal einfach nicht weit genug
gehen also die Idee der Europäer
offene strategische Autonomie so offen
wie möglich aber auch aus autonomen
nötig ist da glaube ich sinnvoller und
jetzt zu diesem Schema zu dem Thema
China entschuldigung es gibt halt immer
Sachen über die man reden kann auch mit
China also sie haben da natürlich
Russland zurecht betont aber globale
öffentliche Güter wie Klima wie
Gesundheit da ist es halt auch bei China
extrem wichtig dass die Amerikaner auch
anders auch die Amerikaner sind da in
china investiert und trotzdem noch mal
die Frage von meinem in dir die liefern
schon heute die USA liefern schon heute
bestimmte Computerchips nicht mehr an
China heißt das dass wir das morgen auch
nicht machen wenn wir in diese
Sanktionen gezwungen wir haben die Chips
gar nicht also morgen geht der
anscheinend nicht weil es hochkomplex
ist aber ich würde mir in der Tat
wünschen dass wir ganz gründlich die
Liste unserer neuen Technologien und
Schlüsseltechnologien durchgehen den
schönen Index von der EU der gefällt mir
gut durchrechnen ja wie abhängig wir so
sind und dann gegebenenfalls sagen nö
oder Option 2 Mitteln also wir machen
das noch aber wir sorgen dafür dass ein
anderes Land gibt wo es auch die
Ressourcen gibt oder die Absatzmärkte
gibt etc und da ganz klar darüber
nachdenken immer diese diese
Diversifikation aufrecht zu erhalten
Peter schmunzelt und Sie müssen sich
bitte kurz halten Entschuldigung
ihre Reaktion ja gerade deswegen gibt es
ja diesen Handels und und Technologie
Rat der Europäischen Union und
Washington aber ich würde vielleicht
einfach nur warnen wenn es zwischen
Washington und Peking Streitigkeiten
gibt wenn sie sich streiten und das ist
jetzt vorprogrammiert wahrscheinlich für
Jahrzehnte wird in Peking Zuckerbrot für
Deutschland gebacken und da würde ich
nur warnen das wird vielleicht
verlockend wirken in den kommenden
Monaten und Jahren habe ich irgendwann
einmal kommt dann auch die chinesische
Peitsche das haben wir in den USA auch
schon gespielt man denke unsere
Filmindustrie oder zum Beispiel unsere
sportliga unsere NBA die üben jetzt
schon selbst Zensur aber es ist Sorge
tragen dass sie den chinesischen Markt
verlieren und da hat man auch den
Eindruck dass so manche deutsche
multinationale Firma die vielleicht im
Singen auch einen Sitzsack da sich
regelmäßig auch zurückhält also eine
dunkle Zukunft wenn man jetzt jetzt
schon die Schritte unternimmt um sich
zusammen zu setzen und der überlegen wie
man da diese Kinderfrage bewältigt
würden sie dann denken dass Washington
die deutschen zwingen kann sich zwischen
den USA und China entscheiden zu müssen
in manchen Fragen gibt es sicherlich
Druck in der halbleiterfrage zum
Beispiel ist ja schon angesprochen haben
und es werden schwierige Entscheidungen
bevorstehen aber gezwungen ich würde
lieber ich weiß überreden oder
vielleicht einen gemeinsamen Strang
ziehen in der Stadt dass man sich jetzt
gegenseitig insbesondere in der
Öffentlichkeit ja bekämpft wir sind
leider schon über die Ohren